a volcano erupts i'm throwing myself
into the unknown
i almost guarantee you're gonna survive
all right
a six-part disney plus original series
there's a new breed of explorers taking
knee to the ends of the earth
to discover hidden worlds
that sit beyond our senses jut from the
earth will and a man in helmets and
harnesses repel down one how's that
feeling scary as hell you know exactly
how it's feeling
from national geographic once you decode
the mysteries darren aronofsky you can
find crucial information about the world
around us will smith ready when you are
we're trying to see the invisible wow
will rides a boat
so i could be one of the first people to
ever see this
inside the sub at 3 000 feet and the
only thing protecting you is about six
inches of plastic we down here y'all
we're down here
we've never seen a world like this a
climber repels in a cave you gotta be
kidding me a turtle crawls on sand
that's beautiful wow
anything dangling just you
a helmeted man crosses a chasm by a rope
i'm not going to need to do that two
times
white dots form root like tendrils that
looks crazy birds fly fish dart it's a
different planet down there scuba divers
shine light how did i not know that this
was in the world will grasp hands with a
guide then hugs another he clasps his
hands as people dance around him flashes
of divers butterflies wildebeest and
climbers a mini sub travels through an
underwater plume wow
i'm still putting this in a movie
i'm so quick
welcome to earth original series
streaming december 8th only on disney
plus